hey you guys
here's the movie that won the patreon
poll this week
going back to italy going back to giallo
yeah
actually this is uh i would even call
this one a proto slasher
it's a good movie i liked it it is it's
a classic uh
this kind of makes sense it
now giallo's kind of it makes more sense
than some of the other ones yeah
known for not making a whole lot of
sense it's just more like a damn visual
and emotional experience
so it does deliver yeah good color
palette
lots of nudity lots of titties yeah
good-looking good-looking
broads
[Laughter]
70s fashion a lot of sexuality
you know violence which is one of the
things i always i always loved about
these
movies i mean other than like the cool
violence and stuff
i always really liked seeing the cool
outfits because i do feel like
um giallo movies in general in the 60s
and 70s were kind of
almost um it was kind of like a show
place for like milan fashion
yeah you know what i mean everybody was
like super fashionable and like were
these
kind of high falutin they were models or
like something like that
and i also like the interiors you know
like where they shoot the [ __ ] like in
people's apartments and stuff like that
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous and in an
italian in an italian shallow movie you
can't be an ugly girl and be in this
movie
they're all like models yeah unless
you're like an old cleaning lady right
yeah yeah
but if you're gonna be headlining these
movies you're gonna be hot
and you're gonna show your boobies yeah
and then they're gonna
and they're gonna
okay look i have to understand the era i
was growing up in this era
all right and the american equivalent of
these kind of
girls in movies tended to be what we
call coke horse
they were [ __ ] super super [ __ ]
skinny there wasn't much damn
shape to them a 70s style
with the bell bottoms and the hip
huggers and the [ __ ] uh
tube top type [ __ ] tank top weird tops
you know
it looked it looked decent on that kind
of figure
well some of the pants they had back
then you'd have to be skinny because
some of these
some of the skinny women in this i still
can't figure out how they got those
pants on
right cocaine was a thing i mean you
know it wasn't they weren't it wasn't
even all that illegal
yeah you know what i mean they just got
it they did it
and they got real skinny now italy
wasn't so extreme they weren't so bad
these women kind of have shape to them
yeah i feel like italy always
appreciated right they have shape to
them and so
they're not russ meyer type shape but
i'm kind of more more in line with what
russ meyers like
but yeah good looking girls real cool
70s fashion
you know and uh like you said interiors
and a decent soundtrack yeah not really
soundtrack called scores
yeah score like a lot of them had you
know obviously very famously dario
magento had you know a lot of prog rock
or you know things like that
i feel like a lot of them had like real
jazz scores
which may have been picked up from like
the german like crimi films or whatever
they called them which were kind of like
based around the same
thing because a lot of them had like
free jazz type scores and stuff too so i
feel like that's where the influence
came from
yeah and you gotta remember you know
story really isn't the strong part in
any italian movie that's not why you
went to see
these and that's not why the audience
went they went
for the emotional and visual experience
of it
yeah it was art yeah it was like being
on a ride
like a ride at a disneyland or in this
case it'd be like like a
like a like a haunted house ride or
something you know what i mean where
slasher [ __ ] was happening and there was
high girls and then there was dudes and
they all looked guilty in this movies
right there
every dude in this looks like a guilty
ass curve
[Laughter]
he did it oh i never did it i feel like
i feel like
that well yeah that's kind of like um
par for the chorus for a lot of jayla
movies because they're trying to set up
a lot of red herrings because it's a
murder mystery
yeah so um every dude is always like a
sketchy creep
that you think it's any one of them
could be the killer because they're all
just so
shady they all got the [ __ ] mustaches
and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] sideburns and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up hair
and they're all like leering and yeah
glasses
beaten up prostitutes yeah they're
always smashing what they do in this one
too yeah they're always smacking a [ __ ]
if you're in an italian movie as a man
you must smack a [ __ ]
yeah which is why when we did that when
we did the review on
the editor that you know modern day like
giallo uh
you know parody kind of that's what i
thought was so funny about like all the
dudes just like beating the [ __ ] in the
middle of just a minute
just how dare you because i'm like yeah
that's about right and you know
today that [ __ ] wouldn't fly like all
that's misogynistic you know
well it is but it is but the thing is is
that
that did not happen in real life that
didn't happen in real life if dudes
acted like that
other dudes would whip their ass as they
get arrested but they put the [ __ ] in
the movie like it was cool
like yeah yeah it's like you don't take
any back talking we don't
broke any back talk from ours i think a
lot of it what it was
is it it's always the dude it's doing is
always
he's always kind of like portrayed as
emotional you know what i mean yeah it's
like
there's got to be certain limits if a
woman's talking crazy to you and you
don't do anything
back does that mean what she says
doesn't matter
[Laughter]
these [ __ ] are emotional oh you
say something you hurt my
feelings i love you too much cause i
slap you
that was the kind of it's like
bullfighting that's what the
that's what they're talking about that's
what they're talking about
i love you so much i must beat you
that's that's that's what they're
talking about
you feel like that's kind of where they
were that's what they were coming from
but there is
there is some of that in this movie
because it's you're like
you know a woman cheats on you and you
don't do anything it's like oh well [ __ ]
her i don't care
yeah you're like so then you don't love
her right so you know i love you so i
must punish you
yeah i i can see where that where that
that's what they were doing
but yeah like i said you were supposed
to be impressed what a great lover he
was
he loved that woman so much he slapped
her
but it was just the thinking of the time
and it looked good on film uh
yeah they really did it because i think
james bond pulled some of that too like
back when sean connery was playing him
yeah yeah i don't think they really did
it in real life though
i don't think that was well i'm sure
some people did but yeah that was an
[ __ ]
yeah i think women would leave you uh
well unless she was italian woman she
might go i love you even more
pow and then she would smack him back
[Laughter]
she would just punch him in the face
that's kind of latin light and [ __ ] you
know
it is it is heightened emotions yeah but
yeah so up in brazil i'm
thinking back yeah they'll just be
slapping each other in the middle of the
street
well it's mostly dude just sitting there
and her slapping him
you know you cheated on me yes i did i'm
guilty
well then he deserve it again
i love you but i love her too i can love
two people i have so much love to give
trying it wasn't love baby i paid for it
[Laughter]
it was just a professional relationship
yeah which like i said
uh the the dude that gets uh real slappy
with a with a woman in this one she is a
prostitute yeah in this one he just
starts smacking her around
because i get well because he can't get
it up yeah because he shouldn't get it
up
so he his little uh ego he said you're
gay you can't get it
well actually he started kind of
strangling her too well yeah you know
and kind of like in the mind of a 70s
italian movie star man
to to not to retaliate would mean that
yes you are gay
yeah they're like i have to do something
you have a friend of mine
you have offended my honor yeah miss
yeah if i don't slap you the audience
will think i'm gay
so did we even mention this movie is
torso all right so
this came out in 1973 and like i said
this is really interesting because
we've talked about this before how the
giallo uh
genre um i feel like american slasher
movies really do owe a lot to that yes
you had the
um kind of psychological horror films
you had peeping tom you had psycho
you had those and you know there's been
movies like this like sprinkled
throughout
you know film history but i feel like
the slasher a lot of the slasher tropes
come almost directly from uh giallo
movies
and this one in particular as i said now
this came out in 1973 so i think a lot
of people will point to maybe like black
christmas
is like one of the first slashers but
that came out like a year after this
um i would argue that probably the first
slasher that you would recognize as a
slasher
is probably bay of blood uh aka twitch
of the death nerve which came out in
1971
which was the first one that had like a
whole bunch of people at a lake
and um there was somebody picking them
off one by one and it was like a lot of
killer pov shots and [ __ ] like that
um friday the 13th very notoriously like
ripped it off
a couple of scenes like almost directly
from that movie
but this movie too very very
recognizably
a slasher i think i would call this
morris lasher than a jello even though
it does have
the obligatory black gloved killer like
and
with the white mask who's like stalking
people and it's a murder mystery
everybody's a red herring
you know it could be anybody and you
find out that the reason that the killer
is doing it
is from some like psycho sexual drama
that he went like trauma that he went
through like as a child
which is very very very common so
yeah i have to say even though this is
called torso
in the u.s i've also seen it called
carnal knowledge
however the italian title which is much
better
um is the bodies bare traces of carnal
knowledge which is one of the most
giallo titles
yeah that's italian [ __ ] that is italian
as [ __ ] but i just i really really like
that title
and the thing about it is that i guess
the the
title torso is like you know it's it's
brief it kind of like gives you and it
had like the thing with the saw like on
the cover and everything
so you kind of knew what you were
getting into when this was released in
the u.s
uh fun fact it was actually usually a
double bill with the texas chainsaw
massacre which came out a year later
than this
so yeah basically this is directed by
sergio martino now he did
a [ __ ] ton of giallo movies um
i haven't seen all of them because his
filmography is
huge but i have seen a bunch of them and
shutter just added a bunch of them too
they just added the whip in the body
which was one of his earlier films
uh strange vice of mrs ward which is
very good also
curse of the scorpion's tail which i
like um all the colors of the dark which
might be i know this is like maybe a
controversial opinion of people that
like giallo movies but i think i might
like all the colors of the dark a little
bit better than torso just because it
was like had a weird
psychedelic kind of tinge to it that
this one doesn't really have
but you know that's completely
negligible like i said he made like a
whole bunch of other ones
so basically what happens in torso
is that there's all these students
at i guess it's like some kind of
university or something and they're all
studying art history
and so they start getting like right at
the beginning
there's a couple having sex in the car
well honestly like the first
i think the very first shot of this
movie is tits
you know what i mean it's it's tits and
there's like a threesome going on
you know what i mean so like as soon as
this you're like oh okay here we go
and there's a lot of tips they're
reminding you where this movie came from
right yeah
before the before the title even comes
on the screen
there are boobs well most of the people
in the audience at the time probably
young italian guys
oh yeah oh yeah only paid a nickel to
see the [ __ ] back they said
no somebody said that in um in one of
the youtube comments when we were
talking about how cheap the movies were
back then
um they said back in the 70s movie was
three dollars three dollars it was three
dollars
like about that so not i mean even even
in the u.s i don't think it was a nickel
said like back in the 40s maybe
i heard that it was like much cheaper
i saw a documentary they were talking
about what the prices although
they were actually talking about
spaghetti westerns yeah and spaghetti
west
a lot of the spaghetti western sucked
from it from here yeah
you know you're not talking about sergio
leone you know what i mean all of them
we're actually who is it yeah i was
thinking about it yeah
most of the guys making them were
[ __ ] hacks
and uh they said that a movie was like
15 cents
a nick quarter quarter for those
maybe maybe it was the price depending
on what kind of movie it was
yeah maybe like well this movie is going
to suck so we're just going to charge
you guys
we're going to charge you before
documentaries
[Laughter]
i wasn't living in italy at the time
that would be super funny
if that it would be nice if like they
would charge you you know in relation to
the quality of the movie
well that would be cool probably the
quality of the theater too
okay well yeah i you would think that if
you were going to like well i mean
yeah the same thing would apply here
well just like here we used to have back
in the day you used to have like the
dollar theater and that was like where
all the second run [ __ ] would play and
like
yeah after the [ __ ] had already been it
was really real basic in there
yeah it did you know you didn't have
yeah none of that could survive today i
don't think i mean i saw a lot of movies
in the dollar theater at daytona yeah
because you know we couldn't really
afford the movies are kind of expensive
and you couldn't really afford like the
fancy [ __ ] and like we're like well i
don't really need to see that
all that badly i can wait like a month
we had one here it closed
yeah there was one in michigan that uh
my buddy mike used to work at it's
called showboat trenton
michigan oh yeah it's gone yeah was that
a chain
i don't know oh okay so just called
showboat showboat there's dollar
show boating well the good thing about
showboat is that they would rerun movies
yeah [ __ ] that you missed like you could
see you know
back to the future one like three years
later
because back in the old days it was
really hard to like watch it at home
yeah even with you know well you
couldn't see it in hd
turn your vhs copy of it wasn't gonna be
that good yeah
you know so for a dollar you could go
back and see you know because they get
old movies
yeah good ones that were old they'd play
those
so i guess they were privately owned
yeah you know
but yeah maybe they play [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] too well yeah that's because that's
[ __ ] free so they might as well
making money but yeah so you have all
these students at this
uh art history college and like i said
everything
i mean it's italy and it's like right in
the middle i think it was shot in uh
perugia i guess is how you pronounce
that i'm not really sure
and um so it's just like this the
cathedrals and like the [ __ ]
michelangelo looking ceilings on the
[ __ ] it's like it's fantastic
so that's where they're having their um
their classes and whatnot
so it ends up that one of the students
flo
is having sex with her boyfriend out in
the car
like out in the middle of nowhere by
these ruins or whatever
and they both get murdered by this
you know masked and gloved killer so at
this stage everyone's kind of freaking
out and then there's um
much like in many other giallo movies
there's always like one
detail not always but there's like
usually a detail
that one of the people has seen but they
can't really remember it and that's kind
of like the key to the whole mystery
so you know it was done in bird with a
crystal plumage it was done with a bunch
of other ones
so in this one basically it's like they
one of the um victims gets strangled
with this
particular scarf that's like red and
black and
the cops come to the class and they're
just basically like okay well
if you've seen anybody wearing this let
us know because this is what the victim
would strangle with so we're assuming
that the killer was wearing it
so then one of the students
um she remembers i saw somebody wearing
that but i can't remember
who it is so that was kind of like a
thing where you know just through the
movie she's trying to remember like who
it was that she's all wearing this
particular thing
um i will point out that this movie also
has
kind of the final girl trope uh as well
like pretty uh blatantly the girl's name
is danny now in the movie
interestingly the version that they have
on shutter because usually when you see
a lot of glo movies and you see
these italian horror movies they're
usually dubbed into english at least the
vid
the versions that we get over here this
one
interestingly is in italian but a lot of
the actors in it like susie kendall
who plays you know the final girl she's
actually british and you can tell if
you're looking at her mouth she's
speaking english and a bunch of the
other actors look like they're speaking
english too
but the version that's on shutter is
like actually so they dubbed it over
into italian that's the version that's
on there
i guess there's another version that has
an english dub and i think there's one
that's
you know part english part italian i
don't know there's a whole bunch of
different versions of this
the italians knew how to make money yeah
they shot a movie
then they dubbed that movie in about
nine different languages
so it didn't matter what language the
actor was speaking
they were dubbed in every language yeah
that's what they well they just i guess
they just figured it was easier
yeah you know what i mean they're just
like everybody just say your lines in
whatever language you speak
and then we'll just dump it all into the
different versions of that [ __ ] that
they sent out to the way probably
a japanese version oh i'm sure they did
yeah and two they had to make different
cuts of it
because you know in different countries
yeah you can't have like super
gory [ __ ] and you know tits and
everything like that so you have to like
recut it for different markets
so that's why i think that's part of the
reason why there's so many
yeah if you try to sell just titles
that's that's not a big enough market
yeah and i feel like this one did really
well like kind of on the grindhouse
circuit like i said it was usually like
a double bill with texas chainsaw
massacre
so people uh were actually like aware of
it at the time and like i said i think
it was like a really um
really influential on later slasher
movies because like i said it's got the
final girl thing it's got like the
killer pov
it's got people being killed with you
know bladed weapons being stabbed and
strangled and whatnot
so it's got all that [ __ ] going on um i
should point out too that
that suzy kendall who plays danny uh you
know she plays an american in the movie
even though everyone's speaking italian
but she's actually british and she was
also in dario argento's bird with the
crystal plumage
because i was watching it and i was like
god damn it i've seen that woman before
somewhere and that's
where i had seen her it's funny as a kid
having hbo and cinemax they'd show us
these italian movies all the time a lot
of them were jello movies that were
watching
we'd see the english dub and i was
looking at him as funny because i could
tell some
some of it was english dialogue yeah but
then other people were dubbed
into english why what the hell i never i
never didn't figure out what the [ __ ]
that was as a kid it wasn't
as much later it wasn't until much later
did i even know these were italian
movies or that italian movies existed
yeah yeah cause you know you didn't
really pay close attention to it
yeah you're just like oh i'm just i
don't know i'm just watching the [ __ ]
there's boobs and people are getting cut
up that's all i need to know kind of
weird how
that dude's mouth yeah
i did notice that weird how story didn't
really make sense who wrote that [ __ ]
i don't know why i was like what were
they on yeah i know it was like that
you know looks different than the other
movies yeah but i didn't i didn't put
two and two together i was it's kid
seven eight nine ten
yeah you don't really like understand
the intricacies of dubbing like when
you're a little
actually i probably didn't realize until
i was maybe about 13 or 14 that there
was such a thing as an italian movie
i didn't even know there was such a
country i thought it was amazing well
you know
you gotta remember what it was like back
then remember how you is that
those four networks had ev every bit of
television space locked up
and then [ __ ] when cable came new
channels appeared
but they were all american you know what
i mean it seemed to be the american
programming just dominated everything
they were going to put foreign stuff on
there
cinemax and hbo the movie channels were
different though
they put a foreign movie on there and it
took me a while to [ __ ] realize that
it was foreign
you saw it too on like a lot of smaller
local stations that didn't have a lot of
um content yeah that didn't have a lot
of content so they would just like get
these they would buy like these packages
of cheap ass movies
yeah and a lot of them were foreign and
stuff as well but we're dubbed into
because there was like a lot of
um like japanese monster movies and
stuff like that had these really
terrible like english
dubs and english cups i knew there were
japanese foreign movies that was obvious
yeah you could just tell you know
because they were japanese people
but uh i didn't realize that you know
italy made movies
yeah yeah just didn't you yeah they have
a they have nothing huge
film industry that movie was kind of
different than the other ones
yeah you know yeah
weird yeah i had a hard time coming to
grips with british movies
that's really funny i'd see a british
movie and i'm like where the hell is
that
people and then he like oh that's
england and i said okay well where's
that in the united states
yeah i'll be near new england somewhere
the state of new england i think you
think that was a state
you know well you know back in the 70s
and 80s you know the united states was a
big place you couldn't drive across that
the cars wouldn't make it
yeah let's say unreliable well yeah it's
like more than three thousand miles yeah
each state was like a different country
yeah no names of them all are down fifty
i haven't [ __ ]
you didn't know that song what's that no
that 50 nifty united
states song that's how i still remember
all the names in alphabetical order
because of that [ __ ] song
no it took me a while to realize that
[ __ ] england was not in the united
states
i didn't realize that i don't think i
realized that until i was maybe seventh
eighth grade seventh grade
by the eighth grade i realized i knew
that that was another country of course
yeah that that was across the world i
would hope so yeah
i think my english i'm trying to
remember what i knew back then
yeah but i used to watch british movies
like i saw dave the trivets
right oh that was a good one that
[ __ ] tripped me out
i couldn't figure out where that was
happening you know
why is it funny cars and [ __ ] you
know why are the cars so i thought it
was just their license plates are all
weird
that was around here somewhere you
thought it was some town you never
yeah i mean about seven
eight that's pretty funny yeah i was
still living in california
about seven or eight i was like man
that's [ __ ] weird place yeah you
might
so you might very well have seen this
movie and not even been aware of it yeah
although i feel like this is something
that i mean this is this is not for
children
it's not um this one is not real it's
not super gory i don't even think it's
as gory or violent as
bay of blood was i don't remember any
slasher since i was about 12 or 13 that
was
that was that's about the time where
like hbo and cinemax where it was in the
house yeah
that's when you saw that kind of stuff
yeah i think i was probably 10 or 11.
maybe
but i don't remember seeing any jala
movies until later if i did i did i
didn't remember them or it didn't like
really register because i did watch a
lot of horror movies
but um yeah so basically what happens is
that
this one girls you know she's convinced
that
she's seen this scarf on somebody so
they do they definitely try to like red
herring you because there's this one
the the prostitute slapping guy who is
also
stalking her um you know and he won't
leave her alone
he's one of those kind of like you know
we we have to be together and she's like
um would you please go away i don't like
you and like he just like keeps
persisting
like he won't leave so they're really
setting it up that he's the killer or
maybe it's like the creepy guy
like in the in the palazzo that just
like selling the scarves to the people
maybe it's this guy maybe later on
there's a doctor it's like maybe it's
that guy
and [ __ ] like that so i do feel like one
thing that
um that it kind of does when they make a
giallo
and every man in it is just like a
sketchy
creep is that you know that the killer's
got to be the one that's the least
sketchy creep
you know what i'm saying yeah and that
is definitely the case in this one
because as soon as
they introduce all the male characters
and there's one that's like kind of
normal you're like that's the killer
right there
and i was right yeah and i don't think
i've ever seen this but yeah so
basically what happens
so she's uh getting stalked there's a
murderer running around
who is like brutally butchered like two
people who are having sex in a car
so what ends up happening is the one
girl she has an
uncle and there's a scene and i didn't
realize it was her uncle until later on
like when she called him uncle whatever
his name was
i thought that that was her husband and
he was just like way older
because they were acting like not like
an uncle and niece
not probably not real unusual for the
70s maybe not like she's all hugging on
him and he's like in the room and she's
just in a towel
and [ __ ] like that really we're not
really related
yeah and he's like her he's like old
enough to be her grandpa
probably like you know what i mean
because she seemed like she was maybe 20
and he
seemed 70s wasn't experimental
it was i mean there's a there's a
[ __ ] uh interracial lesbian
relationship going on
which that that was just going to point
that out because two of the women
because what ends up happening is the
girls end up going to this uncle's like
villa like in this other village to hide
and um yeah and there's definitely a
scene where
oh yeah they're all into it yeah it's
like interracial
a lesbian love scene it's pretty graphic
for the time yeah yeah
they hide it yeah it's like behind a bed
post or something like that
but it's like they show them making out
they show both their tits they show
yeah the the movie's showing you that
[ __ ] these are modern people with
modern relationships they're not tied up
in that old [ __ ]
if if the if the niece and the uncle
want to get it on that's going to happen
if these two chicks the white one in the
black and want to get it on they're
going to happen so that's what they're
telling you
yeah it's all good this is some
progressive [ __ ]
although the uncle thing well they
didn't make out or anything i just
thought it was a little weird like they
were super huggy and then like i
i was like i wouldn't want to like get
out of the shower and be in my bedroom
with it with a towel on and then have my
uncle come in and be like hugging me and
i just want to tell you that's really
weird yeah exactly what he's like three
times my age
that's exactly what they're talking
about though don't be naive that's
exactly what they're talking about
because from this same era i remember
there were movies where obviously
the [ __ ] 12 year old girl and the 40
year old dude are [ __ ] getting it on
it does seem like that and it's like
they're showing you that
or they're they're trying to tell you
that that [ __ ] was normal
so that's low leadership some low
leadership that you know it's just
progressive stuff just where i'll be
free man
be free that's what they were doing well
i'm not a hippie era i'm kind of like
be free with it but within limits i mean
there is that's
that's why they're trying to get roman
polanski back yeah i guess
that and telling you man these the old
these old [ __ ] these all
these old [ __ ] that are running around
today these boomers
were doing that [ __ ] oh i'm sure they
were doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] right they
were
smoking pot and [ __ ] and then they get
older and tell everybody
but yeah i was a kid when i was a kid we
used to go to [ __ ] yosemite national
forest
and the [ __ ] my aunts and everything
and they were teenagers early 20s
they'd be sitting around the campfire
and the damn
park rangers would show up with a
[ __ ] guitar and start singing [ __ ]
john denver songs and passing out weed
to the girls you go down to the [ __ ]
um the to the lake and it was people of
all ages kids teenagers and adults down
there [ __ ]
uh totally nude nude sunbathing and
stuff in
in sequoia national park it was just
normal
there's a lot of nude sunbathing in this
movie too yeah i mean
today that would be like oh my god
around all these children that would be
at only
like a nude beach but in california in
the 70s they just
nobody naked yeah i'm [ __ ] going down
there as a little kid [ __ ] come
around the corner and looking like 15
year old girls coming around the corner
they were older than me just [ __ ]
totally dude and [ __ ]
yeah i was like whoa you got used to it
real quick
well yeah after a while it doesn't get
done just like you
did whatever right yeah it's weird
but yeah that's what's kind of funny at
the time there was a scene of this too
because like i said so all the girls go
to this kind of isolated villa because
they're supposed to be like hiding or
that's where they're gonna be safe or
whatever
however um it ends up that the killer
actually ends up following them there
now interestingly i think honestly i
think
um there's two scenes in particular that
i really really liked in this one one of
them
was when one of the students gets
murdered she goes to this like hippie
party
where you know somebody's playing a
guitar and like dancing around like
naked in the middle of the room and like
all these other pieces these ones are
having sex every year these ones are
smoking pot there's like all kind of
[ __ ] going on
you know what i do you know what i mean
and so she goes to that like two guys
are trying to like make out with her and
she's just kind of like ah [ __ ] this and
she leaves
and then inexplicably she's walking
through like [ __ ]
a swamp i don't really know why but
i'm not gonna complain about it too much
because it looks really cool like the
way that it's shot
she's just like walking through this
[ __ ] swamp and then like far away
there's like the shadow of like the
killer and then he comes and gets her
and she's like all
muddy and where her tits are all muddy
and whatnot so this is so that was like
really good that was a really good scene
and i think probably the best part of
this movie
is like the third act because after the
girls all get to the villa
and the killer gets there he ends up
killing the one stalker guy that you
thought was the killer like one of the
red herring dudes
ends up killing that guy and ends up
killing three of the women
like you don't see it it kind of happens
off screen um but what ends up happening
is the main character
whose name is jane and she's played by
susie kendall as i mentioned earlier
um she ends up she like falls down the
stairs
and i don't think she breaks her ankle
but she sprains it like she can't really
walk on it
so she and she's like oh man i said this
was supposed to be like a good vacation
and now my
ankles all [ __ ] up and i ruined it but
the fact that that happened to her and
she was up in the bedroom
and she was kind of drugged out because
the doctor came over and gave her some
painkillers
she wasn't downstairs when all the other
girls got murdered so she's like the
last one
so there's this really great sequence
probably like the last 20 minutes of the
movie
where the killer is down there like
cutting up you know the other
bodies of the girls and like carting
them away for whatever nefarious purpose
and he doesn't know that she's up there
at first so she's kind of like trying to
you know she's hobbling around and she's
kind of trying to make it look like
there's nobody in the room and she's
kind of like trying to clean up like all
you know trace that somebody else is in
there and all this other kind of [ __ ]
and then finally he like twigs onto the
fact that she's in there
and he locks her in and then she tries
to get the key and then he figures out
where she's at
and so it's like a really good like
suspenseful
20 minutes and i don't think there's any
dialogue or anything like that
so i think that's probably like the best
uh part of the movie for me
like i said i'm not entirely sure why
it's called torso other than just
because there's so many tits in it
it doesn't matter because i mean just
because you know it's a torso but but i
figure
well because what ends up happening is
that you're talking about the plot of a
giallo movie yeah
yeah this does have a plot it makes
sense it does it kind of makes sense
it's just
it's italian yeah that's not
the plot is not the [ __ ] essence of
the story they
they weren't focused on that well
clearly they weren't focused like i said
they were like hot ladies
yeah boobs and splash scenes and
colorful and with music and fashion
yeah it's it was something called
spamoni you ever heard of spomoni
i remember you you talking about that
like i can't say like what movie were we
talking about
i don't remember that italians have an
ice cream that is like their version of
neapolitan
it's got chocolate vanilla strawberry
and [ __ ] pistachio all right and then
they put a bunch of swirls in it like
strawberry swirls and cherry swirls with
whole cherries in there and nuts and
[ __ ] fudge it's every [ __ ] ice
cream you can imagine in every [ __ ]
topping mixed in together and they call
this just pomoni
it's overpowering it it has its own
flavor
but it doesn't taste like any of those
ice creams that's kind of the way their
movies were everything that they did
back in the 70s
we would call that just pomona it's just
they just put everything together i
think you were
you were talking about that when we were
talking about house by the cemetery
because i think that was the last
italian movie that we reviewed yeah if
you like this movie
that's in it if you like that movie it's
in it if you like this movie it's in
there if you like that movie it's in
there
if you like this it's in it's in it's
it's just everything is [ __ ] in the
goddamn movie although i feel like this
one is a lot more cozy
a little more controlled because i mean
when you see movies like you know dario
argento's movies and lucio fulges movies
they tend to be a lot more dreamlike and
you know have a lot less logic
whereas this one is more like a
straightforward slasher straightforward
crime thriller
so it does have like some weird [ __ ] in
it but not that much weird [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's not like it it
doesn't have any scenes in it where
you're like what the [ __ ]
did i just watch or what the [ __ ] does
that mean it doesn't have anything like
that it's pretty straightforward like
when you do get down to it it's a very
simple story it doesn't really matter it
is that's what i mean
so um as i was mentioning earlier
because every dude in this
is just like this creepy gross like
[ __ ] lech or whatever so you have to
assume
that the nicest person or the most
normal dude in it is the killer and that
is indeed the case spoiler alert
uh the killer in this one is the
actually the university professor
franz and the the reason that he has for
killing people which is a very
which is a very giallo uh motive
was that when he was a kid he had a twin
brother
and the twin brother was
he wanted to look at this little they
were hanging out with this little girl
and he wanted to look at the little
girl's panties
and the little girl was like okay well
you can look at my panties but you have
to go get my doll which is right there
at the edge of this very precarious
cliff
so then the twin goes to get the doll
and um not surprisingly falls over the
cliff like to his death in a very
hilarious like hey child going over the
cliff kind of scene i don't know it was
just really funny to me
and uh so ever since then franz has
blamed
all women for his brother's death and he
and he
like um he he thinks of all women as
like
dolls and also there was i i liked too
that just the first scene of it which is
the threesome with all the titties and
stuff because i said even before the
[ __ ] titles come on it's like hey
tits and a threesome
um that actually does tie back to his uh
motive for starting the murders because
i guess that he got sucked into this
threesome
with two of the women who got killed and
then they tried to blackmail him
because i guess he's a teacher so he's
killed them and then he figured well i
already killed two people so might as
well just keep on going because then
it'll cover up um you know my
involvement you know what i mean because
it'll just seem like a random serial
killer like a not mate
yeah um so that's kind of why he started
doing it but he did like
actually have a motivation so i do like
like at the end he has this really like
overwrought
like excellent scooby-doo explanation of
like why he did the [ __ ]
but like i said it's very very giallo
like the it's always
it always has something to do with
something that happened in your
childhood and it was usually some kind
of sexual trauma
or your brother died again and that yeah
it is it's very very freudian so it's
like a very common
trope so it happens in this one too but
like i said if you're into italian
cinema if you're into slasher movies and
are interested to see
um you know where some of the roots of
the slasher movie came from
and you know if you're interested to see
a movie that is very recognizably a
slasher even before
black christmas uh because this came out
about about a year before that
then definitely check out uh torso
although like i said i like the italian
uh
the italian title better because i just
i love those operatic like
giallo titles i just really love those
so torso is kind of like
yeah okay that's i can see what you're
doing but yeah so
definitely check it out it's on um it's
on
shutter at the moment it's probably on
some other places as well
um i don't really know if the english
dub is any good so because i saw the
italian
version so if you want to watch the
english dub then
by all means go and find that but i'm
pretty sure the one on shutter is only
in italian i didn't see if you could
change the
uh the audio track on it but yeah so
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective
we will see you on the next one
arrivaderci